حاول رئيس اللجنة الأولمبية الدولية
إبعاد السياسة
عن الألعاب الشتوية في بكين
توماس باخ قائلاً إنه نقل تلك
الرسالة إلى اللجنة المنظمة لأولمبياد بكين
بعد تصريحات أدلى
بها المتحدث باسم
اللجنة يوم الخميس والتي ردت على سؤال CNN
حول الاتهامات الموجهة للمسلمين.  يتعرض
مجتمع الأويغور في مقاطعة
شينجيانغ الصينية للعمل القسري ،
وأعتقد أن ما يسمى بالعمل الجبري في
شينجيانغ هو أكاذيب من صنع مجموعات متعمدة
، وقد قدمت المنظمات ذات الصلة
قدرًا كبيرًا من الحقائق
للخلاف حول ذلك ، لكن جماعات حقوق الإنسان تقول
أجبرت الحكومة الصينية
مئات الآلاف من الأويغور على قطف
قطع القطن لصناعة أجزاء الكمبيوتر والقيام
بأعمال قسرية أخرى في شينجيانغ
وتتهم الحكومة الأمريكية النظام الصيني
بارتكاب جرائم أسوأ إبادة جماعية
في شينجيانغ
تعتقد جماعات حقوق الإنسان أن
الصينيين اعتقلوا  إلى مليوني إيغور في
ما يسمونه معسكرات إعادة التأهيل في
شينجيانغ وقد وثقوا
المعاملة التي يقولون إنهم تلقوها
لسنوات والتي تشمل التعذيب
والعنف الجنسي
والاضطهاد ، وتتبع نعومي كيكلر
حوادث الإبادة الجماعية
لمتحف ذكرى الهولوكوست الأمريكي في واشنطن ،
وقد رأينا جهدًا مقصودًا
لتقليل قدرتهم على إنجاب الأطفال
بالقوة.  تعقيم النساء
بوضع اللولب بالقوة على النساء اللائي
ينقلن الأطفال بعيدًا عن
عائلاتهم ويفصل بين الرجال والنساء
حتى لا ينجبوا أطفالًا ، هل تعتقد
أنهم
يحاولون عمدًا القضاء على هذه
المجموعة من الأشخاص مما رأيناه ،
هناك مؤشرات قوية جدًا على أن
هذا هو الحال
لا ينكر الصينيون ذلك فحسب ، بل في
مراسم افتتاح الألعاب الشتوية
، كان لديهم متزلج عبر الريف من
الأويغور يشارك في إضاءة
المرجل الأولمبي الذي
وصفه سفير أمريكا لدى الأمم المتحدة بأنه
جهد من الصينيين  يصرف انتباهنا
عن القضية الحقيقية هنا وهي أن
الأويغور يتعرضون للتعذيب أ  الأويغور
هم ضحايا انتهاكات حقوق
الإنسان التي
ارتكبها الصينيون بالنسبة لنعومي كيكولر ، كانت صورة مصباح الشعلة الأويغور
بمثابة تذكير صارخ
بجهد مزعج آخر في الدعاية الأولمبية في
برلين عام 1936. إنه يعيدني حقًا
إلى التفكير
في شعور اليهود في عام 1936
1936 كان اضطهاد اليهود
جاريًا